they give you this integral they say
because X on sine squared X plus 1 with
respect to X and their answer apparently
is this ok now you have reason to be
suspicious lots of reasons number one
what's the derivative of log cos x so
it's almost hand it's negative 10 isn't
it right course enough ok negative 10
can you squeeze negative 10 out of that
well you've got some problems in before
you know anything about it cos x where
the discontinuities are cos x where are
the discontinuities across next it
doesn't have any right where the
discontinuities insiders doesn't have
any when does sine squared X plus 1
when's it going to be equal to 0
it's squared squared now then you think
about what make you tan looks like guess
what they don't even bear her like a
slight resemblance okay so there's your
first problem you shouldn't know that
primitive no a no no no no no way
the other issue is somewhat perplexing
Li and this is a team results exercise I
think okay now when you look at this you
try putting in your tier results your
big problem is this guy this same square
you end up with the team the power of
four and he's going to feel where to go
right so being that I give you like
clues number one that this answer is
bogus number two that you don't need T
results for this come on stare out at me
with me what could we possibly do what
do you have in your tool kit that you
can use on this thing not T results it's
not gonna be a long integration what
kind of integration could you do it by
parts
you can have a cos x and you have a one
over sine squared plus the one other
side skip this one's not going to be
nice come on fix it bluff thank simpler
three unit you can do this question
substitution what sure it's an easy
choice because you have the derivative
all you put to you and yes right there
do you see it yeah okay let's do it
so you've got cos x DX already there so
now you've got a 1 with respect to you
what do you get here that's you squared
plus 1 we're in a second you know what
he is what's that it's the square root
that's tan inverse isn't it that's the
tan inverse of was tenuous of you but
you know what you is everybody
I do want a refund because I didn't I
didn't realize I i faithfully went at t
results and I thought no no this is this
is going down the gurgler okay and then
I realized deal clue your clue and my
clue was that the you've got the cos x
DX there which is related to sign in
such a simple way so you know this is
the I think this is the dangerous thing
with for you integration if you learn
all these awesome methods right and you
start to forget you start to forget
simple things you like integration by
parts yes no okay